our first idea was to write a very
everyday movie about a superhero and his
sidekick and the relationship about that
and kind of explore the inherent dynamic
issues that would arise from that and we
honestly just stopped thinking about it
for years and then one day someone said
The Green Hornet was looking for writers
and we thought oh we both watched The
Green Hornet and we always want to make
this movie about a hero and his sidekick
and that could be the kind of thing that
could be perfect and it would get a lot
of money so he can make a big movie and
it would be about a hero in a psychic
because that's exactly what the green
arts about and people know Bruce Lee
he's really famous so that the sidekicks
almost more famous than the hero so that
was like a really interesting aspect to
of it to us so it all just kind of came
together and it was very every day which
we liked I mean they don't have any
superpowers there's no supernatural
elements to it they have a car that
shoots missiles which is something that
you could build in real life and there's
no technology that doesn't exist in this
world it's very obtainable just for a
lot of money from the producer side of
things you know a lot of car companies
wanted to make the car and it was a big
big decision as to what car to use oddly
enough and it's so funny in retrofit
because we ended up with the pretty much
exact car from the TV show but there was
a huge discussion as it should it be a
new car butyou know she wmw cars should
it be a futuristic looking car and all
these car companies made bids to make
these futuristic crazy versions of their
cars and none of them looked as cool no
car and so we just kind of had our
production designer do a version the
original car and and as soon as we saw
just the regular Chrysler Imperial it
was really cool before they even made
into a black beauty like even that was
cooler than a lot of these kind of
concept cars that we were looking at it
just look meaner and it looked more
again looked more obtainable looked more
like something you could actually build
or have in your real life we always
wanted it to be three days so it
honestly it changed it changed our
vision when the studio told us we
couldn't film it in 3d and we actually
tried to film it in a way hoping that we
would be given the money to turn it into
3d later just hoping that they would see
something they liked enough to give us
way more money basically because as you
know the movie was kind of off - it had
it's it starts and stops I guess you
would say and you know it costs
cost me it takes a lot it takes more
time to film a movie in 3d and
logistically it can be more complicated
the cameras can have technical issues
because it's kind of new systems
sometimes and and so they weren't
willing to commit to give us the money
when we started to filming but every day
we were filming so free like man you'll
be really cool when they let us turn
this into 3d and they finally did so a
lot of the action concepts were actually
designed in 3d and then we were
basically we we were flattening it and
then kind of reexpansion